Welcome back to your Danish citizenship exam companion.
This is Chapter Two, Episode Three, Part Two.
Now to the third power: the courts, domstolene.
They hold the judicial power.
This is laid down in the constitution.
Danish courts are independent.
That means the Folketing and the government cannot concretely decide how the courts should judge in a trial.
Judges are appointed on the recommendation of an independent Judicial Appointments Council, Dommerudnævnelsesråd.
To be appointed as a Supreme Court judge, you must also first be assessed as suitable by the Supreme Court.
And judges can, as a clear main rule, not be dismissed administratively.
In the constitution it says that in their calling, judges have only to follow the law.
The courts must function as impartial conflict-solvers that everyone can trust.
A judge must appear neutral when in court.
A judge may therefore not wear symbols that indicate a religious or political conviction.
This is meant to support general trust in the courts.
The courts can also control the Folketing's laws.
The Folketing must not act in conflict with the constitution.
That means the courts can take a stand on whether a law conflicts with the constitution.
In that case, the courts can set the law aside, even if it has been passed by a majority in the Folketing.
The Danish courts have, however, so far been very cautious about setting laws aside, even though it has actually happened.
In quite a few other countries, it is more common that the courts carry out a more thorough check on whether laws comply with the country's constitution.
The courts also control the government and the public administration.
The courts can thus decide whether, for example, a ministry or a municipality has made an unlawful decision in a case.
Today, citizens also have many other options if they want to complain about the public administration.
For example, several boards have been established that supplement the courts and have the task of deciding complaint cases.
It is also possible to complain to the Parliamentary Ombudsman, who can express criticism of the authorities' decisions or case handling.
Finally, it is the courts' task to solve legal conflicts between citizens, and to pass judgment in criminal cases, where a citizen is accused of having committed something punishable.
Now the structure.
The highest court in Denmark is the Supreme Court, Højesteret.
It has existed since 1661.
The Supreme Court first and foremost deals with cases that have previously been handled in one of the two high courts, the landsretter.
It is therefore said that the Supreme Court is a court of appeal.
That means you cannot bring cases directly to the Supreme Court.
The Supreme Court's judgments are final and cannot be appealed.
Cases begin, as a main rule, in the city court, the byret.
A case can normally be appealed once.
It is said that you have the right to have your case tried in two instances, the two-instance principle.
If a case begins in the city court, it can as a main rule be appealed to the high court.
A case which has been appealed from the city court to the high court can be appealed to the Supreme Court with a special permission.
The city court is the first court instance in Denmark, the high court the second, and the Supreme Court the third and last.
There is one Supreme Court, two high courts and 24 city courts.
In addition, there is the Maritime and Commercial Court in Copenhagen, which especially deals with cases where great knowledge of business conditions is important.
Greenland and the Faroe Islands have their own courts.
The Faroe Islands have the Court of the Faroe Islands.
Greenland has four district courts, as well as the Court of Greenland and the High Court of Greenland.
The courts in Greenland and the Faroe Islands are integrated with the Danish legal system, and their decisions can in the end be appealed to the Supreme Court, just like Danish judgments in lower courts.
Here is your recap for Episode Three.
The government holds the executive power and drafts most bills.
A majority government has a majority in the Folketing; since the Second World War most governments have been minority governments, supported by support parties.
The four oldest parties, the Social Democrats, Venstre, the Social Liberal Party and the Conservative People's Party, are the government-bearing parties.
Since 1920, no single party has had a majority, which created the cooperating democracy.
Prime minister years since 1901: Social Democrats 63, Venstre 37, Social Liberal Party 12, Conservatives 10.
Hilmar Baunsgaard of the Social Liberal Party was prime minister in 1968 to 71.
A minister can appoint one to three special advisers; civil servants are neutral.
There have been 17 to 25 ministers in each government since 2000, and a minister need not be a member of the Folketing.
The Folketing is elected for at most four years, and the prime minister can call an election at any time.
The courts are independent; the Supreme Court has existed since 1661; there is one Supreme Court, two high courts and 24 city courts; and a judge may not wear religious or political symbols.
Now it is time for your exam practice.
These are real questions from past Danish citizenship exams on what you just heard.
For each one, I will read the question and the choices, then pause so you can pick your answer, and then I will give you the correct answer.
Question 1.
May a judge wear religious symbols in a courtroom in Denmark?
Option A: Yes.
Option B: No.
[DA] Må en dommer bære religiøse symboler i en retssal i Danmark?  A: Ja  |  B: Nej
The answer is B: No.
It appeared in the June 2020 and November 2021 exams.
[DA] ✔ B: Nej
Question 2.
Can the government decide how a judge should rule in a specific trial?
Option A: No.
Option B: Yes.
[DA] Kan regeringen bestemme, hvordan en dommer skal dømme i en konkret retssag?  A: Nej  |  B: Ja
The answer is A: No.
It appeared in the June 2021 and June 2022 exams.
[DA] ✔ A: Nej
Question 3.
What is the highest court in Denmark called?
Option A: Landsretten, the High Court.
Option B: Højesteret, the Supreme Court.
Option C: Statsretten.
[DA] Hvad hedder den øverste domstol i Danmark?  A: Landsretten  |  B: Højesteret  |  C: Statsretten
The answer is B: Højesteret, the Supreme Court.
It appeared in the November 2021 exam.
[DA] ✔ B: Højesteret
Question 4.
Where can a decision from the city court, byretten, be appealed?
Option A: The High Court, Landsretten.
Option B: The Supreme Court, Højesteret.
[DA] Hvortil kan man anke en afgørelse fra byretten?  A: Landsretten  |  B: Højesteret
The answer is A: The High Court, Landsretten.
It appeared in the June 2022 and November 2023 exams.
[DA] ✔ A: Landsretten
That's the end of this part.
Well done.